did you ever
[Music]
why would you bet on goliath when we got
bet david valuetainment giving values
contagious
[Music]
all right episode 187 and it's a special
one because of what happened yesterday
after attorney general leticia jackson
james james not lebron james cousins
no no no leticia james
uh uh went after uh president trump he
promised she made will cover that and
civil fraud lawsuit yeah civil fraud
lawsuit talking about 250 million
dollars at best if not at you know
higher end of three to four times
and banning them from doing real estate
and business in new york uh permanently
uh uh and one of them was five years i
mean anyways we'll cover the details on
that but we have a special uh show here
because
today's show we have stuart kaplan on
let me tell you who stewart kaplan is
which the timing is
again could have been better he's a
former fbi agent he received an
appointment with the fbi as a special
agent in 1995 was assigned to the new
york fbi special operations division and
white collar squad
then he worked on some of the most
important cases in fbi history to
include the centennial bombing
and twa flight 800 investigation in 2001
he received a special transfer to miami
division where he was involved in the
anthrax and 9 11 investigations in 2003
was assigned to a long-term
undercover operation and he's now a
criminal defense attorney and we also
have ricky aguilar in the house
he's back and we'll have scott perry at
around 10 o'clock congressman whose
phone was seized i think just a few days
ago to talk about how that just took
place but with that being said stuart
ricky thank you for being on thank you
for having me thank you good morning
stuart how you doing i'm doing fine good
morning so your accent sounds like
you're southern like texas is it's texas
accent yeah southern kind of like across
the cross
bronx southern bronx south bronx
yeah i figured so stuart uh uh when you
see all the stuff that's going on right
now what are you thinking like half of
this stuff like one week it's mar-a-lago
next week is this what do you think is
going on well first of all you know i
when i talk i talk facts because you
know there's a lot of you know
speculation and rumors
and so i tell people when i go back to
when i came out of the academy and i
remember there were 48 of us in a
graduating class 95 back in 1995.
most of the individuals whether they
were men or women and and by the way i
apologize i hope i can use
yes
well i just read in the newspaper if you
come out of the navy now or the air
force you can't refer to mom and dad so
i just want to make sure i don't have
the semen and not science or something
like that but you know most of us were
um
a personalities played competitive
sports a lot of military guys special
force guys real hard chargers
and i saw quickly after 9 11 where the
mission of the fbi changed drastically
where it became more of an intelligence
gathering community they started to crew
recruit more intellectual type of
individuals
and the posturing as i see today for
example when i look at young kids going
through athletics my son plays organized
sports in particular at 12 years old he
plays football
and they're more they're more concerned
about giving participation trophies
our society has changed we're soft now
in fact i remember when
we went through defensive tactics and
they asked everybody in the class to
raise their hand and ask who's ever been
involved in a fight
basically you saw about 50 or 60 percent
of the people raise their hands i can
tell you without a question because i've
been back to chronicle many many times
where you see the same type of question
being asked and no one will raise their
hand who's ever gotten punched in the
face and you look are you being serious
i'm dead serious today absolutely
how is that even possible because
because the mission of the bureau has
changed yeah we as a society has changed
we
law enforcement as in the practice of
law has become more of a sporting
contest it's about winning at all cost
where when i came out of the academy it
was about the administration of justice
it was about equal justice and it was
about arresting bad people going after
top 10 fugitives people that were
murderers bank robberies if i was to
tell you that unless someone jumps the
counter of a bank with a firearm the fbi
doesn't even respond that's today in
2022
but if we have this political
undercurrent where we want to go after a
political figure that seems to be the
top of the priority at this point and so
the complete mission the complete
priority and of course
the
mentality of the fbi and i and when i
talk about the the mentality and i can
talk because i still have one friend
who is actually the second
in charge the seventh floor mentality
that said fbi headquarters
has
changed its focus has changed um i think
that if there was any mistake that
donald trump made when james comey back
in 2017
was escorted out of fbi headquarters the
one mistake he left is that he left the
stench behind that continues to permeate
and he should have cleaned out
fbi headquarters from top to bottom and
why do i say that because 99 of the men
and women who are in the field offices
throughout the united states and
throughout the world are incredible
people and they do an incredible job
but
let's be honest the mission or the
signals are given from fbi headquarters
and so what you see played out now is
like a sporting contest because people
interject their political views they
pull they interject their personal views
and that's not the fbi that i know
the fbi that i know looks at the facts
we're facts based we run out facts to
their logical conclusions and we allow
the facts to speak for themselves we
don't come to the conclusion and work
backwards and create a narrative and
what you're seeing is now everybody has
a foregone conclusion and just like you
talk about the attorney general in new
york who you know i know a lot about
surety
said when she ran for office that this
was gonna be her conclusion she just
needed now to write her narrative and so
yesterday you see her get up in front of
a podium and now she's gonna talk about
her narrative but she had already
reached her conclusions that's not
what i'm all about and that's not what
the fbi should be all about we had a ci
agent here
last week or two weeks ago and maybe
three weeks ago andy bustamente was a
former cia guy and i was asking a
question about fbi cia dea all these
guys
when was it you know how the whole
approval rating would president is this
the oh bring you
when was fbi's approval rating by the
you know populist the highest when did
america trust fbi the most
you know i will tell you that
sitting here today and i can talk to you
about waco
ruby ridge the centennial bombing flight
tw 800 there were many times that there
were isolated incidents that the fbi
became front and center where there was
some criticism
but it was focused solely on decisions
that were made at the time on the ground
this is the first time in my opinion
that the legitimacy or the integrity of
the institution
is now being challenged or being
questioned
and
i do believe that in this particular
situation perception in the optics
sometimes is our reality
and so this is a different
fbi
and you have to question what their
motivation is
i do not recall
politics
ever being interjected into any of the
cases that i were involved in and that's
not to say that i wasn't involved in
public corruption cases right but the
party affiliation of the individual was
of zero consequence
the only issue at hand was whether or
not
there was some
facts
that supported the hypothesis that this
person may have engaged in criminal
activity you run out those leads to its
logical conclusion
not because the person was republican or
not because the person was democratic
but because the person either did or did
not commit a crime and if the person did
not commit a crime that was it the case
died on the vine that's not the
situation we have today
yeah i i wonder like okay so you
originally when fbi got started with j
edgar hoover when you say not political
a lot of it with the stories you hear
about them and kennedy kennedy's coming
over saying hey you better stay away
from us because let me tell you what
picture we got of you and you know
whether it's true or not you know the
cross-dressing back in the days was a
big deal and if the world got out so
there was politics involved the mob was
involved now how much of this is factual
or not i wasn't there in the rooms to
hear about it but we've all read these
stories and seen the movies
what was the original outcome of why we
started the fbi well look the fbi was
started because there was a need there
was a
you know we needed a federal
law enforcement agency to oversee state
and local agencies and that really was
then the embassy or the uh how the fbi
was born to come i don't disa i don't
disagree with you look the director of
the fbi regardless of who the director
is
he serves at the pleasure of the
president of the united states and i am
not going to say i would be less than
candid to say that if the president or
one of his aides picks up the phone and
calls the director and says listen i
need you to do this this and this i'm
not going to say that the fbi director
is not going to jump through
jump through hoops to try to satisfy the
requests of the president
that's not what i'm talking about
because that's in all life that's in
corporate america that's in sports
that's in anything we you know you know
someone you reach out to them you ask
them to you look you get caught going
down the turnpike and you get a speeding
ticket and maybe you have a deputy
friend and you call your deputy friend
and say hey do you know this deputy he
wrote me a ticket can you make a phone
call and tell him to take easy that's
that's in all walks of life right but
that's not what i'm talking about
this now
is an fbi who's been a fbi agency that's
been weaponized yeah by the by the
political
incumbents by by the presidency by the
you know the oval office that's
unprecedented
in modern history so if i could ask you
a question i'm sorry pat
when you say that
um
is that on both sides of the spectrum
both sides of the aisle or is it just
one have you noticed it more recently in
the past 10 15 years when when did you
notice that shift and if so has it been
one side of the aisle more than the
other so look if we talk specifically
about the then former president donald
trump
donald trump
was an icon in new york city before he
even thought about running for public
public office there were a lot of people
that loved him and there were a lot of
people that hated him right and that's
because of his verbose
antagonistic just bombastic type of
attitude in fact i was laughing last
night you know he was on sean hannity
and there's a perfect example where i
can comment as a criminal defense
attorney
that's why sometimes he puts his foot in
his own mouth because the lawyers have
no client control right there is no
reason why he should have gone on that
program yesterday given what was said
earlier in the afternoon but the bottom
line is he was loved and he was hated at
the same time
when he then decided to enter into
public service or to enter into the
arena to run for president no one really
took him seriously i mean that's the
reality he was either the laughing stock
right or as you saw quickly people said
wait a minute this guy may be able to go
to washington dc and shake things up
right and then all of a sudden the fear
started to permeate this could be real
this could be real and and for the first
time
you have people like pelosi or chuck
schumer who've been there forever yeah
and by the way they have taken full
advantage and even biden who's been
there forever and you know the
interesting thing is when you talk about
biden why don't we talk about the last
40 years that he was in public office
let's talk about the lack of success
right he never did anything successful
right and the and the funny thing is
even when you talk about health care and
you know he talks about we're going to
try to bring down health care costs well
how come no one ever refreshes this
recollection when he stood up with obama
and they talked about you could keep
your own you know keep your own health
insurance and it's going to be a lot
cheaper
well all of a sudden
all of a sudden that went out the door
and so for the first time the
institution
that was so ingrained and was
untouchable
started to get really nervous that this
guy's going to come in and he's going
and he's going to kick us in our rear
end and he's going to expose us for what
for what it is
that's when you started to see
people start to reach out and for
example utilize the fbi and here's a
perfect example the attorney general in
new york this is such a meatball type of
case i mean it's really meatball look
donald trump is a very successful
businessman i don't know anybody at his
level who doesn't have teams of lawyers
teams of firms who are embroiled in
litigation that comes with success right
whether you're donald trump or you're
someone else
it just is amazing and by the way
those cases in new york you would never
hear about them right they would be so
quiet and they would all be resolved
maybe a fine would be paid maybe there
would be a disgorgement of some monies
paid back
it would fly under the radar but here's
a perfect example who who here's a woman
who took the platform now and she's
going to run with it and make a you know
making a nothing out of a federal case
here now are you basically saying but i
want to do this to finish this up and
then we're going to go into our friend
james here we're going to go into it
here this is what i want to ask we've
all had investments before you've had
investments you've had investments
tyler i'm sure has had investments and
you've had investments okay at what one
point you sit there and you say
yeah
shoot i mean plus minus i'm i'm not it's
not there's no benefit to me i'm not
making money on this thing here
if we look at some of these agencies atf
which stands for
alcohol tobacco firearms which all are
like what do you mean we need atf
employing 5200 people how much money are
taxpayers paying for atf we can go away
with atf okay
dea
fbi cia which one of those
organizations and i kind of have an idea
which way you're going to lean but i
want to hear what you're gonna say about
this which one has done more harm than
good for america if you had to choose
one let's put dea aside let's just do ci
and fbi
which one's done more harm than good for
america
well look the central intelligence
agency does not operate
domestically they work strictly
internationally
and they are a critical component of our
national security
the fbi is tasked with protecting our
national security here domestically
and so i'm not going to suggest that
either one of them is not valuable
because they both come with tremendous
value and i will tell you
especially after 9 11 and especially
when you see that when there are
separations of state and local law
enforcement and even separate and
from federal state and local the only
way we are going to be safe here in the
united states is to have federal
partners that work with our state
partners that work with the local
partners and i talk about terrorism
matters terrorism matters believe it or
not
police officers that work each and every
day make contact with you and i make
contact with people all day long
that potential crumb that may be picked
up could be noted in a traffic stop in a
citation in a police report in an
instant report and all of a sudden that
one thread of information a year two
three four five years down the road may
become a critical component in a federal
investigation
our success
and i will say this because we have been
very fortunate since 9 11.
leave out the active shooters and the
mass shootings because we have failed
miserably
with that
but when you talk about domestic
terrorism meaning on the national level
with you know not having another repeat
of 9 11.
the success has come with the fbi
and all of the other law enforcement
agencies working so seamlessly together
jointly and sharing information
the the breakdown prior to 9 11 is
information was not flowing down
it was attempted to be flown you know uh
flow up to the fbi but the fbi was very
uh scarce or very resistant to share
information downward
we now work jointly task we were mostly
made up task force agencies
that's why and i do applaud the fbi for
keeping us safe when it comes to our
national security so i don't think we
could do away
with the fbi but with saying that do i
believe it needs to be retooled and when
i say retooled
retooled at the top
neces not necessarily at the field
office level
the challenge then becomes
accountability who holds who accountable
and you know how do you prevent
a
individual political affiliation and
interest of getting in the way of what
you do and what you look past of i mean
it's a very
very difficult thing to do on how you
hire people like a peter strzok you sit
there and say you think this guy's going
to take sides of course he's going to
take sides and yesterday his tweet you
know talking about all these other
people but
behind closed doors the text getting
caught the concern for me becomes
an organization that powerful with that
much control to walk up to scott perry
congressman which we're going to have
here in a minute i don't know the man i
don't know what he stands for i you know
i i don't think he's somebody that's on
tv on a daily basis but with what
happened here we'll talk about him he's
been on for the last few months you're
seeing him regularly with the
insurrection of these different things
but to pull up you're with your family
three kids and like hey hand us your
phone for what
that's that's okay to do nowadays
there there's a part of that that's a
little bit concerning where one side
that approach doesn't work and the other
side it does so it makes a lot of people
a little bit uncomfortable to say at
what point can this happen to me a
regular some of us are immigrants i was
born and raised in iran
people can come and talk to you about a
lot of different things at any time
right people can come in ask you for
things and get away with a lot of stuff
we saw what happened this last week with
a
lady in iran who's 22 years old they're
doing the anti-hijab movement and they
don't want to wear their
hair covers and 22 years old they threw
her in the in the
her head hits it she starts bleeding she
dies the following day and then they say
she died from a heart attack or a 22
year old dies from a heart attack but
it's in iran you know they control the
media they control the story and people
on the streets can do about it but in
america you wouldn't ex you wouldn't
you know think america would get to that
level so my only concern is
what can
what can we do to be a little bit more
uh accountable i know you say tools but
a level of accountability and trust to
be increased if if the fbi was a company
and they had a review online right now
and they had to fix their reputation man
i got a lot of work to do gain the trust
of the american people today i agree
100
but you have to understand and i'm going
to go back to a perfect example just to
put things in context is why the fbi is
not the same fbi that's recognizable not
only to me
but a lot of people that are similarly
situated that have retired and still are
there
when i got into the fbi
there was a fit test the fit test was
you had to run a mile and a half you had
to do sit-ups you had to do push-ups you
had to do pull-ups do you realize now
that the fbi academy has done away with
quote-unquote the fit test now again
don't want to piss off any of the people
that are listening but let's be honest
you have to be fit
because the job should be very
um physically
you know demanding at times and what
happened was there was a person who
couldn't pass the fit test they got
recycled once they got recycled twice
and then on the third time when they
couldn't pass the fit test
they terminated that person you know
what that person did you probably sued
them that's exactly what happened they
sued and then you know what the fbi did
they said well it's a disability the
person's overweight um maybe we don't
need to have the fit test so they disa
they disa they did away with the fit
test
exactly like i say when you have the
participation trophies and now you have
what year was that by the way they did
away with the fit test in
2004 2000 so this has been coming for
death no this is that that's new no no
no this has been coming
correct and now we have how does an fbi
meet his criteria his cr his his
requirements yeah how do they do when i
did that
that was the success of your cases
meaning you know you worked cases you
know if you ended up arresting someone
you got a that a boy
now you have a checklist how many
informants
how many how much restitution how many
seizures how many warrants how many
felony convictions
and so when you break it down into a
checklist
and you have a a chance to go either way
to arrest or not arrest someone well if
you realize you're coming up with your
uh performance appraisal and you need to
arrest someone you're going to arrest
that person why because you got to check
that box
that's not the fbi that's recognizable
to me but when you make it that way
and by the way and what the public
doesn't understand and here's a fact
true scenario
if i come out of podunk
place in the united states out of the
academy and i go to 26 federal plaza
which is where the fbi is located in new
york city you can imagine someone coming
from little place in arkansas who now
has to uproot his family of four and try
to find a place to live within two hours
of new york city because you're not
going to be able to afford an apartment
and now you're going to work at 26
federal plaza you can't find a legal
parking spot and you're absolutely
miserable your kids are miserable your
wife is miserable
here's the reality
after 18 months of coming out of the
academy i can raise my hand and take a
specialty transfer to fbi headquarters
what does that do well you'll spend the
next 18 months at fbi headquarters
and then when you come out of fbi
headquarters you're now a supervisor now
think about this
you're in the bureau
less than four years
and you're going to come out into the
field office and supervise guys that
have 15 20 25 years
that's not gonna work
but you have these young kids that are
doing this
and now you have this culture this
mentality very weird this social media
you know the you know you'll keep in
mind the kids that are coming out of the
academy are driven by social media by
the way when i went into the fbi
you couldn't have ever listen i'm 58 and
i can say this i have never smoked
marijuana
and when i applied to the fbi no drugs
if you had done any drugs in your life
prior to applying to the fbi it was
automatic disqualification right in this
day and age it's now if you haven't done
marijuana in the last three years now
i'm not being critical i'm not taking a
position on marijuana but what i'm
saying is now we've we've changed the
rules we've changed we've lacked some
the applicant the type of individual see
you know the the i want the fbi to have
disciplined individuals and that's why
i'm the biggest advocate for people that
come out of the military why because
they are so disciplined and they don't
ask why they just do it and they stand
at attention they'll stand there for 16
20 24 hours and they won't move they
won't go to the bathroom they won't have
to look at their cell phone you know
when i worked at the fbi you know keep
in mind cell phones were something you
carried in a suitcase so not everybody
had a suitcase right we at best we had a
beeper we had a pager you go into the
fbi you know fbi agents they all have
cell phones everybody's on social media
everybody's getting their media their
their information through
through social media that's making us
brain dead and i think there's a
disconnect you know the public thinks
fbi fbi agents are something above us
being human no the fbi is made up of
human beings men and women and the men
and women that are coming out of college
coming out of graduate school coming out
into the world have this demented
distorted view why
because they're watching tick tock
they're you know facebook and all this
garbage that's being fed that's the new
and upcoming fbi agents we know the
military just recently
is their lowest ever recruiting
shortage they've had in a long time to
the point where now they're given 50 000
bonuses for six years
uh just to join it's like oh you're
physical don't worry about you did so
don't worry about it it's a lot more
don't worry don't worry don't worry then
before i ask the question i think you
posted something
well
as attractive because now you can get
your loan forgiveness you know listen
when when people went to the military
went to the military because it deferred
your expense to go into college right
did not even why do i have to do that
why do i have to need a six-year
commitment to give back to uncle sam and
by the way i'm the biggest
advocate and proponent listen you want
to forgive forgiveness give those people
that raise their hand and volunteer and
god forbid they have to go over into
unforsaken god awful countries to
protect you and i yeah and when they
come back give them a house give them
health care for give them loan
forgiveness that's i'm good with that
but now you just want to give loan
forgiveness because i'm lazy and i don't
want to get off the couch and go get a
job
i don't i don't agree with that so
there's where it's driving also the
military wow i never let me ask you a
point because i don't think anybody
listening to this is going to disagree
with you i think you're making very
valid points i think everything you say
is accurate accurate accurate what i
want to understand is why like what was
the catalyst i said you basically
started off the episodes basically
saying we're getting soft bro straight
up when i joined the fbi i was a macho
guy i played sports competitive now it's
all intellectuals almost bureaucrats
that we talk about um but what was the
catalyst this cause it's this this isn't
a this isn't a trump thing this is an
obama thing you're talking about this
was late 90s early 2000s yeah so what
happened look i saw quickly after 9 11
that the bureau and when we talk when i
say i'm talking about the fbi the
mission of the fbi completely changed
after 9 11 we became an intelligence
gathering agency we were no longer
hands-on and by the way for example when
i came into the fbi
you know i loved going after bank
robbers and you had bank robbery duty
meaning that if there was a bank robbery
and you happened to be on call you went
out and investigated bank robberies in
this day and age and here's a fact
unless there is a weapon used in
connection with a takeover in a bank the
fbi does not even respond to a bank
robbery so the mission changed we became
more concerned about you know
you know profiling individuals and less
about arresting and investigating really
bad people here
who were in seating in our in our
communities that were drug dealers and
human trafficking the you know and while
you think that the fbi mission you know
those things are at the top
that's not that wasn't the focus after 9
11 and so that's where i started to see
the mentality change meaning from the
mission of the bureau and then the
recruitment of individuals now who were
coming into the fbi were different than
i recognized when i came in
and when did you retire from the fbi in
1996 and i'm sorry in 2006. okay so you
haven't been so it's been 15 years plus
years so but i am
hands-on there all the time you know
still have people that are there and so
i i still have a pulse right to
understand
because the older guys you know now i i
see what they're saying i hear what
they're saying and they are frustrated i
bet well my next question was how often
do you interact with these younger guys
not the older guys not the guys in their
60s the 25 year olds who might be saying
look stuart i respect you but you don't
get it man i'm 25 years old i was born
with a phone in my hand how often do you
interact with these younger people so on
my on my lawyering side
all the time every day in fact i told
you i just came back from dallas it's a
case that's being investigated by the
fbi now this agent this case agent
happens to be a 20 i think he's in 20 22
years
the guy is incredible but when you
tackle and you bring in young agents
that i interact with first of all they
come in they have zero people skills
like you and i can have a conversation i
can meet someone without ever knowing
them and they already know about my
background i ask you about your
background and we're just building a
rapport these kids that are coming out
they're so fixated on the script and and
by way of example criminal defense
lawyers they're evil they're the bad
guys they're on the bad side
where i always looked at it when i
engaged in meeting lawyers when i was
with the fbi that was an opportunity to
develop a relationship to develop a
rapport and i've talked about this and
let's talk about mar-a-lago and this is
exactly where there's a disconnect and
where i talk about facts
when i was with the fbi and i would
execute a search warrant if there was a
lawyer that showed up on scene i loved
that why because i would go up to the
lawyer and say hey lawyer i'm looking
for x y and z can you talk to your
client because maybe you can make my
life easier and make your client's life
easier because i don't want to tear tear
apart his house i don't want to disrupt
his family i don't want to start ripping
going through draws i'm just looking for
x y z and the lawyer inevitably would go
sure agent here's where you need to go
here it is and we would go we get it and
leave how often does that happen let me
like
all the time and how many times would
they say here it is
all the time really if the object was
there it was just a matter of time
because oh god you know listen first of
all when you talk about real search
warrants and you talk about the contents
of the affidavit in support of the
search warrant basically there's
something that's called ripeness meaning
fresh information so someone apparently
has
has reliability and credibility to
attest that they have seen what we're
looking for on that oh god so you guys
already know it's there of course and
just like when they got to mar-a-lago
this was not by surprise that they that
they didn't know they were going to find
these boxes of documents someone had
already put their eyes on it so they
already knew that they were going to
find it but this idea to wall off or
keep out of lawyers and and the other
thing is if i was an agent i invited
lawyers to be a bird on a perch they
couldn't interfere with the search but i
always liked that because they kept us
honest and they also prevented from
anybody accusing us of misconduct of
either taking something or destroying
something or going into you know
something that may have made us look
unprecedented why would they do it
without a lawyer being there though
that's very weird so my interpretation
in my opinion is because they went in
under the broadest pretext
knowing that they knew exactly where
these boxes of documents were but they
were also hopeful again the mentality is
let's look everywhere because maybe it's
not necessarily what's described in the
warrant but maybe we'll find other
things maybe related to the january 6th
situation or maybe we'll find something
else some other smoking gun if listen
here's the thing patrick if i'm donald
trump's lawyer and i show up in
mar-a-lago and they give me a copy of
the warren i say okay you guys are
looking for these boxes and these
documents come on in i'm going to walk
you downstairs and say
here they are now you could say
well mr kaplan you know you could keep
documents somewhere else i'd be like
listen let me escort you all through it
but i'm not gonna let you start rifling
through things and start looking at
things that are not specified or
articulated within the warrant and and
what i find so offensive is look and
here's where the breach is and here's
where the dishonesty is
when you are an agent
and your agent's going to execute a
search warrant there is an operation
plan that is put in place days before
the execution of the search warrant and
there's an operational meeting and the
rules of engagement are gone over and so
when you go into someone's house or
someone's office
you don't just grab stuff and throw it
into a box you have to examine what
you're looking at to ensure that you are
legally entitled to take that you can't
just grab documents and throw them in so
but that's the whole point that's what
they did they came in with like a sweet
street sweeper and collected everything
and figured well we'll go through it
later
the breaches and the offense to me is
now we know that there are
indisputable privileged documents
meaning a lawyer
attorney-client privileged documents
that in no way should have ever been
seized and if they were even being
considered to have been taken
as a agent i would have addressed it
with donald trump's lawyers on scene
and to either make an agreement
on location we're going to take the
documents they're going to go into a
yellow envelope they're going to be
specially marked they're going to go to
a taint agent we will not look at them
and they're going to be segregated but
you see none of that was done and
whether it's one document or two
documents when you have that breach
when you have the violation to me it
taints the integrity of the overall
mission and it makes you look
dishonest so to so but to be able to do
that that that means
so in fbi there's got to be democrats
republicans independents so right before
they're about to do something they came
from washington dc patrick they were
flown down they had to leave their
phones and they were flown in
and then they were flown out what does
that mean okay so when i would execute
when i had a case that took me let's say
i'm down in florida
and i develop information that's going
to lead to a search up in atlanta or new
york
i'm going to notify that field office
and they're going to work in concert
with me when it comes time for me to
execute that search warrant i'm not
bringing agents from the miami division
up to georgia or up to new york now as a
case agent i will be there because it's
my case but i'm going to utilize the
local fbi office just out of the
economics of it just out of just the
mere
manpower but that's not the case they
used a squad out of
fbi headquarters men and women who were
flown down specifically for this mission
they did what they did and then they
were flown out and not only that but
they were walled off to communicate with
anybody here why because there was a
concern that either it was going to
leaked out or either that someone here
would not be on board with what they
were going to do did you see the part
when in 60 minutes they asked
biden hey did you know about this
investigation and what his answer was
she heard it his answer was uh uh
i got it right here his answer was uh
you know no i was not aware of it right
but maybe one of my people is look
here's what happens between 4 30 a.m
and 7 30 a.m depending on the
president's schedule and i know that
again fact base
his chief of staff or the president of
the united states is debriefed each and
every day
on the major events that are either
ongoing in the world or that are going
to happen which includes the fbi
director or his elector
of debriefing the president or his chief
of staff there is absolutely no way
that the president of the united states
did not know on that particular day the
fbi was going to mar-a-lago to execute a
search how does somebody not push back
and say how's that possible
because to me if you're the
commander-in-chief how do you not know
that they're about to rate the guy that
was your number one competitor how do
you
do they think the american people are
this dumb and let me let me
take it from there obviously you saw
what happened with the attorney general
leticia leticia james yesterday right i
did it's a very interesting thing tyler
i want you to pull up youtube go to
youtube.com
and here's what i want you to do so the
things that she said if we don't have it
written here because it was last minute
i'll just kind of read some of the stuff
here that audience uh
maybe you didn't see the whole thing so
she called it a white collar financial
crime which you used to be working on
white collar stuff when you were fbi
falsifying financial statements
insurance fraud issuing false statement
to financial institutions
more than 200 misleading asset
statements those years
uh apartments uh was more than thirty
thousand square feet he says but it was
only ten thousand square feet that's
what she's claiming so he inflated the
value department by 200 million dollars
okay
then she says he received 150 million in
favorable interest rates by showing that
his net worth was higher okay mar-a-lago
should have been valued at 75 million
but it was valued at 739 because its top
line revenue of mar-a-lago was only 25
million by the way if mar-a-lago was
really worth only 75 million on the
record i just made a 75 million offer to
buy mar-a-lago if you were saying that
and i'll go half-see with you you want
to do that
the complaint is a 280 page pages long
complaint
and she's asking the court to bar entire
trump family from conducting business in
new york increased network to get
financing uh she doesn't want trump to
ever run a business in new york et
cetera et cetera so 250 million uh fine
and she's saying that's the bottom and
even michael cohen yesterday is like
that's the because i was involved i
would sit there and hear what trump
would say increase my net worth from
three and a half to five and a half to
seven and a half billion he says i've
never seen anybody get richer in ten
seconds like trump would get richer just
by telling us what to put for his net
worth so they're going after him hard
right who said that michael cohen cohen
said that yesterday on cnn and you
realize now
that the complete
premise of the initiation of this woman
doing this investigation was started by
michael cohen who has the credibility of
zero on a scale of one to ten we put him
at zero
there is not one did you see anybody
from jp morgan or bank of america or bb
t or sun trust or any of these those are
the ones that should it's right they
lost the money right well but no one
lost any money and and by the way when
is the last time you could actually ask
to be given money without an independent
appraiser paid for paid for by you but
but done at the behest of a bank because
i mean you buy a house you could tell
them whatever you want but the bank is
not going to rely upon that they're
going to send out an appraisal and
they're going to ensure that the asset
or the collateral right at least reaches
or exceeds what they're going to lend
you i mean did you see any financial
ceos up there or board directors up
there saying we got cheated or we lost
money you know it's crazy though like
you know i've raised a lot of money over
the years and i've sold businesses and
you can say when you're talking you give
them a you know basic sims that you're
giving it to them they're looking at it
right
okay so your ebay does this much your
this is this much you can inflate as
much as you want because what's next is
is a four-week process of quality of
earnings done by third party four you
know accounting firms kpmg pwc you spend
a few hundred thousand dollars to a
million dollars to do quality of
earnings and they're like well this was
off no this was right and the more your
numbers are right the more you're going
to get a favorable valuation that they
give you upfront so that stuff no one's
going to give a few hundred million
dollars without doing their own due
diligence but here's the kicker this is
the point i wanted to make
when she does this fyi she said she was
gonna do it and she did it so to the
people that wanted her in there to go
after trump guess what she kept her
promises okay but i want you to go on
cnn
and go on their youtube channel just go
on youtube channel when she first
announces it so go to videos
yeah go to videos zoom in a little bit
so the audience can see it
so go up go up go up go up keep going
i'll show you this is the i watched so
much cnn today was unbelievable
uh it's the one that says breaking
that's the one okay so click on that but
don't play the audio click on that i
want the audience to see this okay
so she is they're doing what they're
doing turn off the audio and just press
play what the lady is saying right now
she's saying breaking news okay press
pause okay
so press pau okay so this is the first
time
on cnn
an anti-trump camp
is talking about
trump's entire family is getting sued in
new york okay
on a 14 million subscriber channel
zoom in how many views this thing got
zoom in how many views this thing got so
they can see it
this should be 17 million views
10 million views you know what the
american people are saying oh we don't
give a [ __ ] yeah we're over it
but all i'm saying to you
if it was like when russia happened
and what was the guy's name on russia i
know we have information on the what was
the guy's names uh
adam uh adam's ship ship adam ship right
peter schiff's
so when he got up you know how many
views it got nearly 10 million views
eight million views
the american people
simply are sitting there saying listen
man get over it move on we understand
you hate this guy we got it yeah you
hate this guy okay and and
we're fine whether he wins or doesn't
you know totally get it but this is a
little bit too much would you have
guessed tyler
adam would you have guessed for
something like this to get 341 thousand
views breaking news well
i i just think it it speaks to the
credibility of cnn and what people are
watching on there for instance a clip
came up on my youtube just a little
perspective this is a million
uh subscriber channel you familiar with
this guy brian tyler cohen
he speaks out against trump he's
proudly a democrat he's got a million
views same same story and a million
subscribers that's what i'm saying is
that people are looking for other
outlets that maybe
are less biased or have more credibility
you would think like this is a home run
for cnn breaking news this is what's
about to happen and the american people
are saying
let them just compete if he doesn't win
he doesn't how would you compare that to
the to the two or three
videos right before that or after that
is it all sometimes i watched all of
them so zoom out zoom out so you can see
this not even this story i'm saying in
general okay zoom out
go back to the channel yeah just go back
to the channel so zoom in a little bit
so we can see all the views zoom in zoom
and zoom and zoom in
okay so 51 000 it's voter stun
uh zoom in okay so putin people are
interested in putin more than they're
interested in new york you got to be
kidding me
trump's poll numbers are making things
they're more interested in his poll
numbers than their interests so that's
higher biden response to putin okay
they're interested in that
sweeping condemnation heroin and reacts
okay uh uh
589 what's the next one a retired
colonel on potential impact of three
hundred thousand
uh more relationships
yeah exactly but but
michael cohen 599 okay
nothing is in the millions the voters
are telling you cnn move on and let's
see who's going to get elected what are
your thoughts on this just looking at
the optics and the numbers stuart yeah
no i listen i agree i thought it was a
non-factor in fact you know generally
speaking
the attorney general of new york would
have
initiated
a civil investigation meaning they would
have gotten a complaint
through the channels and they would have
investigated it and then if they would
have realized that there may have been
criminal conduct they referred to either
the feds or to the county of which who
would have jurisdiction in this case and
what is left out is that new york county
and also the southern district of new
york had already investigated this and
had already come to the conclusion that
it was a non-issue that there were no
criminal violations so now this woman
who all of a sudden has
some
you know the holy grail is trying to
suggest now not only we can commence
civil litigation civil litigation but we
have the smoking gun to suggest that we
have now evidence of some crime that has
been committed it's hogwash it's it's
nonsense as i told you off camera i said
i bought a lot of popcorn popcorn i'm
going to sit on my couch i'm going to
eat the popcorn and watch this side show
because it's ridiculous
uh i think that um
as i watch the news and obviously
in the hispanic community
everybody watches cnn telemundo right
and um this is making news too
and i think that uh the more i talk to
the hispanic community
uh like going back to what you were
pointing about 341 000 views they have
no idea pat that they are pushing so
many people to become trump fans well
when you push somebody so much
you get to wonder why do you hate him so
much that's what ends up happening like
kind of what happened with andrew t a
lot of people didn't know who andrew
tate was up until you cancelled him not
everybody's looking him up right and i
think that's what's happening right now
that they're just uh
um
people are waking up and like wondering
like man this guy scares you if you're
doing that much you're sending the fbi
to his house and you're doing everything
every time you turn on the news spanish
too there's jorge ramos there's paola
ramos which is his daughter which was
part of a
lot of people don't know hillary
clinton's
um uh
when she was running for president
jorge ramos's daughter was part of that
camp and she was going to have a
position in the white house so a lot of
people didn't know that so he was
politically motivated to go against
trump but you turn on the news
everything's trump like bro he's been
out of office for two years but the more
they do this and they do things like
this it starts to push people towards
them as opposed to against them and this
is him this is backfiring and it's
backfiring nasty especially in our
community they just did a poll that 55
percent of hispanics are not flipping to
become uh to voting for trump in 2024 if
if he decides to run if he's going to
run for whatever 35 55
well he was at a he was he's at a 55
approval rating he was only at a
20-25 percent in 2016. yeah interesting
is that trump or the republican party no
trump specifically bro mexicans don't
know nothing about the republican party
they only they only associate republican
party with trump that's it it's it's
they're they're you know they're not
even magnets they're just like this is
ridiculous you know and they're seeing
especially they're being affected with
their income
with the with the gas prices did you
watch did you watch the interview last
night with hannity did you did you catch
it i did i watched the whole yeah and
you know what's interesting just
listening to him uh and and going back
and forth and you know he's his usual
self and he you know hannity took a shot
at fbi like not a shot shot but he was
kind of trying to set him up to take a
shot at fbi
and
trump's like listen i there's a lot of
great agents there like most of them are
very respectful to me most of them are
very good most of the fbi agents are
great people i don't know if you caught
that one i'm sure i didn't no i did
because like i said when donald trump
was a businessman in new york city yeah
he did interact a lot not only with the
fbi but all across local law enforcement
and he he was
well respected and well liked by the law
enforcement he probably even threw
parties for them or something you know
he was very
and he said look and if you go back and
listen he said the men and women in the
field offices are not the problem it's
the ivory tower meaning it's the seventh
floor mentality that's and that is where
there is a disconnect these cases are
being driven at a headquarters in a
particular you know floor
not the field offices can i give some
stats to essentially what ricky's
showing so you see this one right here
that says the point cnn it's the bottom
right it's probably the most viewed
video on the page right there
if you scroll in on that okay 6.99
exactly so i actually watched that and
this is zero percent my opinion i'm just
summarizing what this was the most
viewed
video on cnn in the last uh 24 hours
aside from the putin one aside from
putin okay ex respect so what ricky is
saying is that he's been out of office
for the last two years which he has and
essentially the story here is that
most presidents when they leave office
when they look back at the poll numbers
uh or approval ratings people will kind
of say all right you know george w bush
has been out of office for a few years a
little bit they forgive him all right
obama's been out and they're
like if they leave office their approval
ratings maybe you're at 50 percent and
then in retrospect you know what he
wasn't so bad it goes up to 60
the challenge that trump is having right
now is he's never really left office
when is he i mean technically i mean i'm
not going q on he's left office okay but
but he's been in the news he's been
campaigning
january 6th mar-a-lago he's not escaping
the media attention so the poll numbers
reflect exactly what they were the day
that january 6 happened so if you want
to this is again these numbers
now i understand a million people have
basically gone over to the republican
party a lot of latinos everything you're
saying is actually factual but if you
take this at its word and i'm going to
read some poll numbers and obviously
i'll give the disclaimer
i don't know if you can believe poll
numbers how much are they right how much
are they accurate so i'll just read you
the numbers nobody's asking me you can
extrapolate exactly i've never been
asked the poll numbers but the poll
numbers basically show that trump still
remains very unpopular here are the
numbers so this is this is nbc
um
and also quinnipiac i don't know how
much credibility you put there again not
my opinion like steward said i'm just
reading the facts that were given to me
uh this is national voters 34 have a
positive
outlook on trump 54 negative that's nbc
that's national registered voters now
according to quinnipiac it's the same
positive 34 favorable
57
unfavorable essentially one in five have
a very positive outlook on trump 46 of a
very negative outlook on trump and the
major major major major major factor is
all the january 6 coverage again i'm
just re i'm summarizing what he said
there i think they're i think they're
they're they're knowing who to ask
because if you ask 10 people that
believe things like you they're gonna
you're gonna have 100 approval you're
not asking us nobody's asking there's
nobody's going to come to my community
and asking us
our communities nobody's asking us okay
if you want
i don't trust the fox pole i don't know
about the cnn poll i don't trust this
nbc poll i don't trust an abc player
i'll i'll trust pew
gallop-ish
and uh maybe one other and all the other
stuff is going to be a little bit like
where are they asking people in their
office yeah they see it in office i'm
with you on this i've never been asked
for a poll ever okay zero so i hear you
on this but here's the anomaly and this
is something i'd talk about just talking
to my neighbors which is mind bad
when you go to the gas pump they don't
ask you before you put your atm card in
there you're democrat or republican
right right you pay the same ungodly
amount i just filled up i think it was
529 a gallon for premium it's seven
dollars a gallon of premium in
california okay
you're not going to get any sympathy
from ricky
brother so here's way worse so here's
here's we've got a good in florida so
let's whatever it is
here's what it is yeah what's the point
as trump was asked last night by hannity
gas prices were below two dollars
when he left office prior to him leaving
office i think he said in november or
october they were like 1.89
what is um amazing to me is if i talk to
someone who is so
steadfast hatred for donald trump
i this is unbelievable and this is where
you have to say cuckoo they hate him so
much they'd rather maybe they pay their
seven dollars so five dollars for gas
than to have gas at a dollar fifty or a
dollar a night now here's the other
thing you go to the supermarket
you know groceries were very reasonable
when donald trump was in office now you
go to buy a gallon of milk it's like six
dollars right yes everybody has to pay
the same thing whether you're hispanic
or african-american or whatever
everybody goes to supermarket they don't
ask for your voter registration card
it's amazing though
that biden has been able to use as a
scapegoat
for his failures
placing it directly on donald trump now
what is crazy about that is donald trump
moved the meter and moved us so far
ahead where we became so uh energy you
know non-non-reliable
right independent and gas and and food
and employment and everything was so
great
and listen i'm the first one to say if
he only could have kept his
side and closed behind closed doors and
not have brought it in front of the
podium
he would have been better received but
the bottom line was he was no nonsense
if he had to get from a to b
he got there as quickly as possible he
cut out all the bureaucratic nonsense
right
you're running right yeah what's wrong
with that stuart
i agree with you but i'm gonna kind of
circle back you're kind of proving my
point is that people will vote against
their own self-interest i'll pay a
dollar more for taxes for hatred just to
not see his face and that's essentially
my point is that yes i agree with you
why wouldn't you want lower inflation
lower taxes lower gas pumps lower
consumer price index of course you want
to pay lower but to not see donald
trump's face i'll pay an extra dollar
and that's the whole point of these
polls you're essentially proving my
point i agree with you i want to pay
less than 10. what about but i want to
pay less but he's not right people are
democrats i don't know this is not
breaking news i don't know the cnn
democrats tend to be a little bit more
emotional than republicans yeah no show
okay so they'll see it you know
thank you pat that smile means a lot to
me
they see donald trump and they get
triggered whether it's right or wrong
it's fact it happens okay i'm learning
i'm reading services i'm trying to be
less emotional here but democrats aren't
haven't come around hold it together
buddy it's going to try to quick
and we'll be all right okay we if we can
uh we have a guest that just joined us
here uh congressman u.s representative
scott perry from pennsylvania's tent
uh district he's a retired pennsylvania
army national guard brigadier
general who just recently
the fbi came up to him and asked him for
his phone and we'd like them to share
that experience with us so uh
uh scott perry thank you for being a
guest here on the podcast
well thanks so much i sure appreciate it
um
look it's not something you aspire to uh
we get uh one month of the year that we
can kind of plan to be with our family
some of it and uh that month is august
so uh my family it's expensive but we so
we all pitch in and we rent a little
house down at the beach at the shore
down at the jersey shore
and uh we spend you know time with the
with the kids with their grandparents
and their uncles and aunts and those
type of things and of course you don't
expect a knock on the door at nine
o'clock on the in the morning
at the shorehouse um because you know
you're you're not you're there with
people you know and people that know you
don't knock on they just come in
so i answered the door and of course i'm
greeted with three by three guys in
suits at the beach which is kind of out
of character so
uh they said good morning congressman
we're here to take your phone i just
happened to have the phone in my hand
and i said you know i put it in my
pocket and i said you know i'm not
giving you anything
until you you know you prove that you
have the authority uh to do that and of
course you know look i looked at the
paperwork
uh i looked through their badges and so
on and so forth and you know they
started asking me questions and look i'm
a guy who grew up revering the fbi the
cia
people in uniform
so this is so out of character but of
course i you know i'm living in the
world of today in america so when they
started asking me questions politely i
said look i got nothing to say to you
people um
and so you know we went through the the
process they gave me a receipt tell me
they're bringing it back you know today
when they're done uh taking an image of
it and uh and they said you have any
questions for me and i said yeah i got a
question for you how did you find me
here
of course i know how they found me there
they're holding in their hands now how
they found me there but i wanted them to
say it
uh and and the gentleman kind of got a
smirk on his face and he said it's just
what we do
and he said we'll contact you when uh
when we're ready to you know give your
phone back and i said well i don't have
a phone to contact me so
can you call my chief of staff and let
her know so she can let me know
you know call my wife or what have you
but i didn't look what i didn't want to
have happen was have the fbi knock on
the door and have my elderly
you know in their 80s father-in-law and
mother-in-law have to go to the door and
deal with that it's just not it's not
appropriate
and uh and and they said well what's her
number i said well i don't know it's in
my phone
and the guy says to me well it's not
like we're going to go rifling through
your phone like you got to be kidding me
uh i said look i don't give you
authorization to do anything but i give
you authorization to get my number from
my chief of staff out of my phone
hours and hours later
my father-in-law is calling my my wife
we're down at the beach with my kids
uh and um
and he says the fbi's here so oh great
you know
so i pack up you know look i'm a typical
dad at the beach i got a cart with all
the kids toys the blanket the umbrellas
all that's chairs all that stuff right i
pack it up like a packed mule i send my
kids back to the house
uh and you know i start heading up the
street you know what i'm looking for not
hard to find at the shore black suv
parked on the side street
i stopped pushing my cart i walk over
towards the towards the vehicle of
course all these guys jump out
walk up to me paperwork my phone i said
to the gentleman i said sir
why could you not honor your commitment
he said what commitment was that i said
the commitment you made to call my chief
of staff instead of bothering my
my father-in-law and my mother-in-law he
said well we couldn't find her
oh come on
i thought that's what you do
you know so that that was my experience
you know they took an image of the phone
and i'm sure look i'm sure they they're
trying to do the paperwork to say they
want to look inside the phone at this
point but uh unfortunately
i'm a little skeptical living in the
world today watching what's happening
i'm sure they have everything they need
off the phone to start with
now you said a lot of things there uh
one
uh you said you asked them how they find
you and yeah you said i'm sure
i know how they found me i i want to say
are you insinuating that the phone and
working with an apple or whoever the
phone company is they located you that
way is that kind of what you're thinking
yeah that's exactly what i'm thinking
it's not like i announced to the world
hey i'm going to be at this address out
of town on this day you know we live in
a dangerous world i got young children
that i'm trying to shield from you know
the rampant crime running across america
right now courtesy of the
leftist democrats so i don't announce
those kind of things i tell people after
the fact hey i was just at so and so
this is what you know but it's after the
fact
uh and so obviously look
we're glad that they can go after
terrorists and criminals and use
technology to do that unfortunately this
is now the new surveillance state where
parents who have the gall to go to a
school board meeting a school that they
pay for in their taxes right under
penalty of law by the way and have the
gall to question what the school is
teaching their children you know the fbi
and the department of justice puts a
threat tag on them that's the world we
live in today now to follow up with that
you know are you droid or are you apple
w what kind of a phone i i i've got an
iphone okay so you got an iphone i
remember you know when the whole san
bernardino thing happened i don't know
if you remember yeah how much heat tim
cook it got for not giving the
information and recent book that just
came out called after steve meaning
after steve jobs
they specifically talked about how the
government didn't like tim cook because
he was close with trump and he was close
with both presidents and they're like
how is it that you're going to be close
to a guy like that he's going to listen
this guy calls i i deal with him so and
uh tim cook most people don't even know
he was a former republican is what he
was tim cook growing up i know that's
going to sound strange but
that's a completely different
conversation the other part of it is
so
you know they said they're going to
bring the phone back i'm assuming they
haven't yet brought the phone back
no they have they have okay
and how much after did they bring you
back how much how many days after did
they bring well they said it was going
to be a couple hours it was the length
of the whole day which quite honestly i
didn't believe a couple hours but why
say a couple hours it's going to take
all day i mean why not just be truthful
about it so how about this now now that
you experienced that have you
changed your approach and philosophy on
how you're
you know handling your phones because
you know most of the time a lot of
people have two phones you know
especially people in your kind of a
position you have to have two phones one
is going to be working personally
has anything with your approach changed
uh quite honestly it hasn't uh look my
life's an open book i don't say anything
on the phone that i would say
publicly you know yeah i objected to the
electors and i explained to the world
why i called for investigations i called
for audits i explained why those
positions haven't changed what my
concern so i'm not concerned about what
i've said on my phone what i've said i
can't control what other people send me
number one number two i absolutely can't
control what the fbi the department of
justice the cia the nsa any of those
three-letter alphabet organizations will
put on my phone i can't control that and
neither can anybody else yeah that's not
comfortable for me because i no it's no
way it's not it's no one's business to
see what i'm telling my wife my kids my
that part there is zero uh i am zero
tolerance for that now let me ask you
what happens if you don't give the
phones let's just say the fbi fbi does
show up and you're like i'm not giving
it to you what would they do to you
i think they would turn you around put
you in handcuffs and haul you away i
mean look that's that's
that's the new police state that we live
in understand on this phone is
attorney-client privilege i asked them i
said look if you wanted the phone why
don't you just contact my attorneys you
know i have attorneys now because of
this whole j6 charade right this this
so-called committee and that one agent
said oh you have so and so and so and so
as your attorneys i said yeah why don't
you just call them
no answer to that um
so
again this is this is the world that we
live in and um
you just got to live that way knowing
that at any moment
this could look they're after me at this
moment they're after mike lindell donald
trump john eastman jeffrey clark you
name it the list is long and
distinguished but that's us today
it's going to be everybody else and they
just hired 87 000 or paid to hire 87 000
irs agents do you think they're going
after
you know uh
the guy that owns uh amazon jeff visa do
you think they're going yeah they're
going not going after mark zuckerberg
they're coming after people that pay
some guy 25 bucks to cut the lawn that
you know
some lady that's trying to work three
jobs to pay for gas food and the cost of
living right now
who who who then said well i'm not at
home so i'm gonna hire somebody for you
know 20 bucks to clean the house you
know
that's who they're coming for so it's me
today it's you tomorrow
congressman stewart kaplan former fbi
now practicing attorney question was the
legal process to get your phone was a
search warrant
yes it was all right now congressman
because i've been in that situation i
will assume the technology that's out
there that the bureau uses is called
cell brite and that's a software that
would mirror your phone i assume the
conversation went something like this
listen congressman let's make your life
a lot easier give us your password
because if you don't give us the
password we're going to keep your phone
infinite it may take us up to a year or
two to crack that code so i assume
you realize that i would need my phone
back so you cooperate and gave your
password is that correct
essentially yeah i scripted almost
exactly
and and so you realize though sir and i
would have counseled you though and
that's only because i've been there i
would have said listen agents good to
meet you go pound sand here's my phone
but i'm not giving you my password and
good luck cracking that code by the way
on cracking an apple iphone probably a
year maybe even longer uh and by that
time you know who knows what happens but
listen in any event i just wanted to
make sure i understand the legal process
now i have a question for you because
this will maybe
cast some information that may assist
the viewing audience
uh
you were left a copy of the warrant what
district
or what jurisdiction was that warrant
issued out of
uh
well i can't remember i don't know if it
was in new jersey or washington d.c
actually i think it was in pennsylvania
they went
to where they were in pennsylvania you
got that warrant
okay but you didn't i think that i think
so i'm not a lawyer so look and i don't
travel with a lawyer i appreciate your
counsel now i wish i had a thing
normally they'll have a uh a usa's
number on it that if your lawyer has any
questions you can contact this ausa i
assume it was a 202 number someone in dc
someone had to justice uh yeah yeah i
think so and i guess i guess i could
have said you know before i hold before
i hand you the phone let me contact my
attorney no i understand that no and
congressman and listen again because
we're having open attorney-client
communications at this point now i'm
joking but do i understand and this is
what would begrudge me and again this
goes to my point where i think the
bureau has really taken a bad turn here
congressman do and by the way you don't
have to answer this i'm making light of
it because i probably already know the
answer do i understand that prior to the
agent showing up at your beautiful
vacation retreat your lawyers or you had
zero contact with anybody through doj
telling you or asking their curiosity to
just sit down and talk to you about what
may be in your phone
this was just awesome no contact
whatsoever yeah so you know the day they
showed up was the day i learned about it
right no and and there lies the rub with
me and i will tell you that you know
in addressing and investigating
political figures such as yourself it
goes to the highest level up to the
director of the fbi and and when i say
up to the director there's got to be 20
indian chiefs in between the director
and who has to sign off on that and
that's where begrudgingly i have a
problem because so many eyes had to have
seen this and the optics and the
perception is so bad
and just is so distasteful that someone
like yourself who now has said and i
think i've heard you say this i'm an
open book whatever i would say
on camera or off camera is going to be
the same so i assume congress if anybody
had any interest in talking to you you
would have sat down and told them what
you would answer their questions
if the department of justice or fbi
would have called my attorneys and said
look we want to sit with the congressman
we want to look at his phone or whatever
it's not the j6 so-called committee
that's a one-sided of course a star
chamber that already has determined the
outcome before they ever talk to anybody
right but this is different the level
was never made right
and and and i can add this because
because this is something that you will
find i think particularly interesting
and egregious
the inspector
general we found out the inspector
general was involved in the decision to
come seize my phone the fbi and doj
inspector general and and the reason how
do you like that well i'll tell you what
the reason is the reason is because
after the fiascos that have been going
on and on and on there is now an
inspector general investigation with
respect to the ethics and the integrity
of what's going on in in at the fbi
headquarters
this is this is the day after they
raided the president's house the
inspector general was involved in the
seizure of a sitting member of
congress's phone and i don't say it that
way because i'm better than anybody else
i'm just citizen perry right but but at
the same time they know that there's
there's attorney-client privileged on
this phone because they know it's my
personal phone and they know i have an
attorney so says the fbi agent that i
spoke to on the street but also i'm a
sitting member of congress and in the
constitution there's this thing called
speech and debate which protects the
legislature from the king from the
executive branch because the king or the
president isn't supposed to be able to
intimidate or coerce legislators to do
what he wants to bend to his will to
bend the knee
and to not say thing on behalf of their
constituent his constituents um
and of course they're trying to pierce
that veil right now and i'm alone out
here in the world trying to hold back
the the kingdom of president biden
against a couple hundred years of of of
you know of courts and and decisions and
litigation that that that separates the
legislative branch from the executive
branch so that we don't have a kingdom
yeah well you know the travesty and the
concern and listen i'm sure you have
very learned and experienced counsel but
my immediate concern and which is
serious is this cell bright technology
does not differentiate between
attorney-client privileged
communications and that that may just be
not and the problem with that is you
realize that a case agent or the
evidence response team is gonna go
through each and every communication in
that phone whether it's privileged or
not and there lies the rub where you
would have and should have had the
opportunity to have your lawyers say
look i'll tell you what we're gonna
segregate the congressman's phone
we will download the phone mutually at a
mutually agreeable time and location but
we are going to before we turn over
we're going to segregate that
information that we know
is attorney client privileged and should
not fall into the hands of the
department of justice and there is where
there's an agreement put in place to
protect someone like himself and to
protect all of us i got two questions
for you what about my conversations with
my constituents that are that where they
talk about their health issues what
about conversations with other
legislators about whatever legislation
president biden might not like or my
opinions about it or strategies maybe to
make sure that it doesn't pass or
that we put some what about all of that
why is that not speech and debate and
how does the executive branch now have
entrees all that stuff and then use it
not only against me but every single
member of my colleagues who i've had a
conversation with so i got two questions
for you so one is so the part about you
can hand the phone over and not give the
password what happens if i do that
you're the fbi agent
you're you're stuck i say here's my
phone good that you've actually you've
complied with the warrant you asked me
for password if i say i'm not going to
give it to you what can you do so what
they can do is they can they could try
to bring you before a court
under a contempt threat of contempt and
try to get you to compel to give you the
password but those cases are limited to
national security where there's imminent
threat to national security okay so
peter so so perfect so peter struck
yesterday not yesterday a couple days
ago tweets this on september 14 he
tweets this and i would share it but i'm
uncomfortable it may drop you so we're
not going to risk sharing it we'll share
it afterwards
he says
at this point fbi may have more cell
phones than verizon okay
then a verizon store giuliani
victoria townsend michael mcdonald scott
perry is referencing you john eastman
jeff clark boris efstein
mike roman mike lindell and then this is
the last sentence and this is a question
for you and congressman perry the fbi
can't seize any of them without probable
cause they contain evidence of a crime
is he right about that last statement
all right so what the reason why i asked
the congressman now
it doesn't necessarily mean that the
congressman and by the way again i'm not
trying to encroach your learning council
but that a affidavit in support of a
search warrant does have to
suggest that there's crime there's
criminal there's fruits that may be
borne out in seizing that item that
doesn't necessarily mean the recipient
of the search warrant is a target or a
subject of the criminal activity the
congressman could have been talking to
or communicating with someone else who
may be the subject in target but
and that begs a little bit of the rub
here because generally speaking in my
world they would be able to get that
side of the conversation through that
other individual meaning serve the exec
execute the warrant against that other
individual so if there's a search
warrant that was executed for the
seizure of the congressman's phone
there is an affidavit that's under
sealed by the way and this is different
than donald trump
his affidavit he does not and i will
assume congressman you haven't been
given the affidavit correct
i have not i have not but
we confirmed we confirmed that day with
the department of justice my attorneys
confirmed that i am not the target of
the investigation so that stopped from
taking the phone so that tells me then
someone that he was talking to or
allegedly yeah someone he was
communicating with is a target or
subject of a criminal investigation and
either their content of that
communication is unavailable or no
longer available and the only way they
were trying to then get that
communication was through this witness
so these so the congressman at best
would be a witness so so then so then
that's the last question and then uh
congressman perry if you got any final
thoughts for the audience or any
rebuttal on what i'm asking here is so
what if in that moment the three fbi
agents are standing in front of new
jersey uh waterfront home that he's on
vacation for uh for a month in the month
of august it's august 14th i believe
it's a date
what if in that moment he says to one of
his kids hey guys can you go to the
garage grab a hammer
bring the hammer out and i start
breaking the phone i think somebody's
done this before in the past
what if he starts breaking the phone
right in front of you being immediately
arrested and charged with obstruction of
justice immediately how come that didn't
happen in the past well look the
differences and i know who we're we're
talking about course okay sweetheart so
she listened but she was not the
recipient at the time she took chemicals
in a sledgehammer to destroy a uh a
computer server
had she done that in realizing that a
that a search warrant was imminently
being served upon her and did that that
individual will be charged with
obstruction and tampering and destroying
of evidence
i was trying to give you an idea but
apparently that what she did in the past
that wouldn't work for you you had to
hand the phone over
final thoughts congressman perry with
everything that's going on right now
with what they did with trump yesterday
i'm sure you saw that as well with uh
you know attorney general what are your
thoughts with that taking place
specifically the last 24 hours
look the tyranny is just going to
ratchet up but people think that this is
going to slow down unfortunately i think
they're wrong this is just beginning and
and while today you know they they're
breathing easy because they're at work
and it's it's it's perry it's trump it's
eastman it's all the people vince
victoria tensing all these people that
you name it's their problem tomorrow
it's going to be your problem if you
don't get it this tyranny that is
sweeping across the country it is you
the democrats the leftist democrats have
now weaponized the instruments of
federal power and are using them against
their political rivals in the united
states of america it's why people
whisper when they give you their
opinions it's why people don't want to
be involved they don't want to come to
events they don't want to be associated
with uh
you know political parties or political
candidates this is a breathtaking
departure from the first amendment this
the fourth amendment you name it the
constitution is being shredded before us
and if we're gonna save it people of
courage are gonna have to be willing to
stand up and and prepared to take what's
what's coming but we're all gonna have
to lock arms and fight this together
well listen next year in august if we
find out through our own intel team if
we know where you are for vacation we
will send an uber each to your front
door with some lobster some bone and
we're buying some fogra
and we won't be asking for your phone
but uh congressman perry thank you so
much for making the time for being a
guest here on the podcast
thank you god bless you keep fighting
the fight take care bye-bye
so so literally if they do come i can
say here's the phone but i'm not giving
you the password and you're fine fifth
amendment
no
entity
no one can compel you to give testimony
against yourself yeah you can't self
recover so and it happens all the time
and those smart individuals those
individuals that are
informed say sure go ahead and take my
phone
i'm not going to give you my password
and i will tell you it is extremely
disruptive and frustrating to an
investigator
listen i'm not going to advocate
anything but i will tell you this from
my right
so listen
now here's fact based versus you know
fiction okay i'm special ops and i've
been tasked by the fbi
to
surveil someone
and capture that individual's password
while he's entering that password or to
see if i can obtain that password in a
public view meaning i'm not
invasion of privacy i'm not violating
the fourth or fifth or sixth amendment
but maybe the congressman is in
you know i make a phone call to the
congressman when he's in the supermarket
and he takes his phone out because i
know i have someone giving him a ruse
call and i'm looking over his shoulder
and i can see what password he puts in
done all the time can you very cameras
to i can use anything i want as long as
i'm not even invading your legally
protected right of privacy so hence if
you're in a place that has video
surveillance for example this room
you've got to come to iowa okay and i
put my password in there is no
expectation of privacy now i may think
you know maybe but if someone captures
my password
and and listen i need that password to
get into your phone
there you go
done all now ricky's not gonna
let me just tell you how this plays out
okay
again fact versus fiction
anytime we would target public officials
in public corruption or
high-profile cases you understand very
different than a donald trump individual
this congressman had a way the equities
of the optics himself and the perception
unto himself
if he did not cooperate with the fbi
because think of the headlines
cnn or the new york times congressman
executed search warrant but fails or
refuses to give his password compliance
what's the conclusion then he's got
something
yeah of course you see but listen
i believe
i still believe in our forefathers and i
still believe that all men all men and
women are innocent until proven guilty
beyond the reasonable doubt and the fact
that someone has a lawyer is in no way
consciousness of guilt and especially
with the way the landscape is you should
have lawyers to keep everybody above
board and the landscape
even that's why the scales of justice by
the way have a blindfold the lady of
justice you know why she has a blindfold
because she doesn't look at the
individual the scales are balanced
because we're blinded we just follow the
facts well listen i have some people
i've interviewed in the past before that
would want to have you as a as their
attorney yeah that's right so we may
make an introduction but only if they
can afford me
it's going to be a it's going to be a
decent-sized retainer okay he lives in
palm beach
you have to you have to come so i want
to i want to play devil's advocate and
go to a completely different side with
stories one with bill barr one with ben
shapiro let's start off with bill barr
okay
so bill barr comes out and says the
following he says uh trump likes to call
anyone who disputes false election fraud
claims as a rhino
former u.s attorney general bill barr
was responding to a rant trump posted on
truth social in
which the former president said he had
no guts and was a weak and pathetic
rhino who was so afraid of being
impeached a rhino for him is anyone who
disagrees with him with the election was
stolen he rebuked he then recalled his
childhood
when he was he passed out
leaflets supporting barry goldwater the
arizona senator who was known as one of
the forefathers of the modern
conservative movement as someone who
handed out barry goldwater literature
when i was 14 years old on the upper
west side it's little it's a little
silly to say that what do you think
about what billboard is saying to trump
look personally
in 2022 or 21 or 20 or 19
in this day and age it's unimaginable
and it's unacceptable to me personally
that quote unquote the legitimacy of any
election
by the casting of one invalid ballot
should ever happen meaning
that if someone is filling out a ballot
and is putting down information of a
person who's deceased or knowingly is
not here legally and not within their
legal right to vote and that vote is
counted to me personally that
makes the entire process illegitimate
and whether it's the one vote to
to cause someone to win or lose or
whether or not it's just one vote that
should not have been counted is enough
for me as being an american
living here in the united states of
america that should say that we don't
accept the election as is and it needs
to be redone and just by virtue of you
when you go to the airport you have to
show a passport a photo id yeah facial
recognition you know this idea that i
need to have an id to prove who i am and
that i am within my legal right as an
american to cast a vote and this idea
and again please hold the hate mail
please
that in some way that's racist
i just can't accept that everybody who
lives in the united states
should be fundamentally
uh
wanting
that an election whether you agree with
it or not needs to be legitimized by
each and every vote that is cast that's
just my personal opinion and i'm sorry
and so i don't get into the weeds of
whether there was enough votes that were
illegitimate to have changed
the outcome
but i do know and by the way it's
indisputable that there was at least one
vote that was cast that was illegitimate
meaning that there were votes that were
cast that happened to be people that
were dead that to me illegitimizes the
entire process that's offensive to me
personally and that's offensive to me as
being an american but that's nothing new
this i mean there's always going to be
one but here's what but here's if you're
talking 160 million votes right the
process the whole election for one
alleged vote we live here in the united
states of america we are the richest
nation on this planet we are the most
sophisticated we listen people are going
to give their lives to come into this
community into this into this country
right we see what's going on at the
border what other country in the world
by the way what other country on the
planet are people literally risking
their lives to get into
none zero only the united states of
america so that should tell us as
americans
that fundamentally we should ensure that
each and every vote that is casted is
legitimate and that person is legally
entitled and by the way
here's where it offends me the most
when you are born here in the united
states by virtue of being born here
you have citizenship you are an american
but i go back to and this is where i
find that we have gotten so far removed
my grandparents who immigrated from
russia and from germany and fled
they spilt their blood they gave their
blood their sweat and tears to come to
the united states to work
live lawfully contribute and provide
i think it's such a disrespect and such
a slap in anybody's face who has come
here legitimately and legally and who
has gone through the process and waited
the five the six to ten to twenty years
whatever it took for them to get and
obtain their citizenship
listen
someone that works for me just got their
citizenship i am telling you when
they speak of it you would think someone
died you would think something horrible
happened the emotion of the gratitude of
what they
exube and the feeling of appreciation to
now saying
they are a citizen is unbelievable
but it's so recognizable because you see
the emotions coming out of these
questions and how disrespectful is it to
allow someone who's not here legitimacy
to be able to cast a vote and to then
skew the election and so my
my long-winded response is
yes it should not be acceptable we do it
again
i'm sorry yeah there's a part of it
there's a part of it that i'll say the
phone remember back in the days we would
take the test and it was multiple choice
right and then they would put it through
the scanning the machine thing and you
remember that whole yeah i think
something 78
right i mean you remember that right
okay al gore and by the way when i took
my insurance license i'll never forget
this i took my insurance license in
november december january like november
december of 01 or january of o2 right
when i went to california department of
insurance and i took my insurance test
no joke
on the test they gave you a paper test
okay
the answers were erased you know how you
circle and you erase i don't know if
you're on someone else yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah they were circled in a race
i'm like i'm looking at the ladies like
oh don't worry about it we don't have
any more to just take it so it's like
but it's your risk if you trust the guy
that erased she said to me
maybe the guy failed so don't trust his
answer i'm like what is this all about
so confusing i'm sitting i'm like okay
[ __ ] i'm gonna go here with this one
it was such a weird scenario but back
then guess what there was more
opportunity for
manipulation today go take your serious
seven when i took my series seven i said
in culver city and everything was five
cameras on you while you're taking your
series seven no joke i'm sitting there
everything was computerized they're
watching exactly what you're doing they
check the id everything
everything was so detailed so let me get
this straight if i can get my series
seven and you're so concerned to see
that it's really me taking my series you
mean to tell me you we can't make it the
same exact way and the level of insult
to believe that immigrants are not
intelligent enough or capable enough to
go get a driver's license or an id that
is an insult to all the smart immigrants
living in america so it's a very that's
the part where it's a little wishy-washy
why protects it so you're more worried
about seven and a license anyways that's
a that's a that's a part that's a little
bit disturbing meaning
i'm not sitting here saying yay or nay
i'm part of your camp where i think it's
always happened right i think fraud uh
election fraud has always happened do we
may or do we whatever we can go back and
give a bunch of stories of all these 7
000 dead people in chicago voted for you
know
kennedy and they never needed in the
first place however
that is not an excuse
for us to use the type of technology we
have i love
global entry you know what i love about
global entry here's what i love about
globalization are you global environment
i'm clear now i love global i love clear
and global industry i love it but i love
global entry more because i just got
back from madrid a week ago or two weeks
ago and i walk up and i just go global
entry i have to go always down because
they they have it for five eight heights
or five so i went like this
it sees my eyes boom go through i don't
have to wait with 600 people so if i can
get global entry and they are able to
see my eyes and it takes a second you
mean to tell me we can't do voting where
i go boom yep it's patrick that david
vote this is what i want to go
i think that is [ __ ] and that's an
excuse i think we have plenty of
capabilities right now many different
places to know
exactly who's voting for for what
and i'd be so curious to know if we did
that
well the how
is the thing is i think that what hap
what happens is that you know being part
of lexi the latinos actually the
democrat party uh group we have these
conversations all the time
and letting in for example they've let
in 2 million 2 million record breaks
record-breaking uh uh illegal immigrants
to the country now we're immigrants my
parents both of them came here illegally
at the beginning but now my dad's a
citizen and my mom is resident everybody
in their my family has papers for the
most part um but but the point is that
um if they if they push these laws like
georgia just did
then what they can do
is that they're sending these these
these immigrants to the states like
swing states and they're trying to push
the id voter id law calling it racist
because now you have a whole new voting
bloc
so when you let like for example my my
grandpa talks about um ronald reagan
like if he was almost like a god
because he's the one that gave amnesty
my grandpa remembers that
so so
to his
there's a dynamic to it some people
don't understand hispanics are very
loyal extremely loyal they're loyal to
their church they're loyal to their
pastors they're loyal to their parents
and they're loyal to anybody that gives
them some help not all of them but for
the majority part
that so much that you can you can you
can literally you can you can you can
show them that the person that they've
been helping them for 10 years or
whatever the case may be is a fraud and
they will not go against that person
that's how deep that loyalty goes so
when you're letting in so many hispanics
and you talk oh and and you know you
know biden was president by them buying
all democrats by them democrats buy them
democrats their loyalty will be there so
when it's time to go vote and that's why
they want to get rid of the voter ids
because they're illegal so if you're
illegal and you don't have an id but you
can still vote that's a whole new voting
bloc so that that's kind of where you
know from what the conversations we're
having with lexit is that's where this
is going because they know you're going
to use their emotions hispanics are very
we have more soul poppers than any other
any other country in the world any other
race in the world we have more soap
operas we're emotional people
soccer they
everything is emotional and so like when
you go to the games
watch the games where people are
fighting there's more fights in the
dodgers stadium than any other stadium
in the country
and it's always hispanics when is it
ever white guys or black guys fighting
it's always expanded they're very
emotional yeah so you let them in we let
you in oh boom you had a new voting
block i would put raiders in there as
well by the way raiders and of course
it's oakland no it's vegas but it's when
you watch the bit if you pay attention
back you see the the fight at this at
the studio at stadiums it's never whites
or blacks it's always hispanics well you
know one time we took about a hundred
people there a guy i don't know you
would know this guy or not one of our
guys
uh you definitely would know who this
guy has been hispanic he's cuban and i
think he's puerto rican you i think yeah
i know exactly who it is
out of dodgers no way yeah but this is
like i want to say 15 years ago 13 years
ago classic story anyway so okay so
that's that part about the voting i
don't think anybody disputes if we can
use global entry eyes if we can use
series seven why not apply some of that
and if we did
things let me put it to you this way
if those if my friends in my history
class weren't sitting next to me when
we're taking exams and i always took the
test by myself i don't know by how much
my score would be lower do you
understand what i just said so there's a
part of it here that applies to this
here as well now next story ben shapiro
got a big following very loyal following
great communicator okay
ceo and founder of daily wire
said the following this is a new york
post story ben shapiro gop cruising
for a bruising by sticking with trump
prominent right-wing media personality
ben shapiro called on the republican
party to ditch former president donald
trump to boost the chances of winning
elections shapiro suggested that gop
should nominate a non-trump candidate in
2024 to make it harder for democrats to
appeal to independent voters there is a
reason
democrats are eager to keep trump at the
center of the conversation half of the
independents say trump is a major
factor in their vote and they're
breaking 4-1 for the democrats
if he runs
republicans shouldn't play
shouldn't play that game if they do
their cruising for bruising do you agree
with them yeah so you know to some
extent i think one of the shortcomings
of donald trump was it was too much
about him
and not enough about the team that he
had assembled in achieving the success
that he did
donald trump did more for this country
in the four years that he was in office
politically meaning in making our lives
that much more prosperous than almost
any other sitting president the problem
is that there's such distaste and we've
talked about it the hatred for the
individual
had donald trump
put his party first meaning had given
more credit yeah to the republican party
yeah
i think people would be more willing to
stick to
voting republican
being meaning being against the
democratic party or against the agenda
as it is today with biden
and i do agree that it is a very savvy
and smart
uh strategy that any association
affiliation with donald trump will then
cause even someone as we talked about
the gas prices to say i'd rather pay
seven dollars than to see that guy back
in office had
the republican party taking the credit
for us making us energy independent gas
at a dollar fifty then they would vote
for republican the problem is tethered
with the devil they're not gonna vote
for the republican party i do believe
there's some credence to that yeah the
most important vote in the country is
the independent vote by far and away we
already know if you're a trump fan if
you're a mega you're going to vote that
way you already know that if you're an
obama person democrat you're gonna vote
that way the independent vote is the
most important voting bloc in the
country and they're typically in the
rust belt whether it's ohio michigan
iowa you know in that area now i can
only take
um
ben shapiro at his word and if we're
gonna take ben shapiro who's a very
educated very wise at his word and he
says
trump is a major factor and independents
are breaking four to one to the
democrats the alarm bell should be
sounding for the republican party if you
nominate trump
you're going to get what's coming to you
the independents are going to break
towards whoever it is and i would hate
for it to be freaking gavin newsom
you're in california you get it and if i
i've said this loudly proudly i would
vote for desantis in a heartbeat i'm not
going to vote for donald trump do you
know you know the easiest ad ever the
easiest ad ever the democrats will do
just play january 6th all throughout
september october till voting day in
november do you want more of this
and you're telling me you're talking
about emotional latinos you're talking
about democrats independents they're
going to see that and be like yeah i'll
pay an extra dollar and guess i'm good
on this
word to the wise listen to ben shapiro
yo all right so here's the retort to
that so you have a guy who walked into
mcdonald's in new york city last week
and had an ax in his backpack yeah and
he went and destroyed the mcdonald's and
obviously put the fear in all those
patrons to think that they were within
milliseconds of losing their life you
know what his bail was
zero he signed himself out of jail and
the mayor and the police commissioner
said
well he really wasn't intending on
hurting anybody he was just you know
destroying property now would you like
to talk to the people that were in the
mcdonald's at the time this guy was
wielding an axe and coming after them
face to face so if that's true then god
bless new york city to have that type of
political affiliation and that type of
continuation because we're going to be
the lawless nation we're right we are
teetering it's happening it and by the
way it's happening as we are watching it
happen and again it's unbelievable that
people are embracing that it's okay yeah
well may i report to your retorts yes
okay you you're an fbi agent so you
should have done your reconnaissance did
you see what happened before that four
people were beating the [ __ ] out of him
and he stood there getting pummeled and
then he reached into his backpack after
escaping the ass whooping and got his
axe okay let's record that but i'm going
to return that what does that have to do
with donald trump people not like a
donald trump because donald trump is
about law and order and gave the
deference and the respect
to law enforcement if you go back to
barack obama uh
but that still doesn't answer what
venture bureau
but it's a carryover when i think four
or five police officers were shot and
killed in houston or dallas which is
disgusting and nobody
dallas thank you and he sat on his hands
and would not acknowledge the loss of
life in house obama obama disgusting
but that sent that set
when you look back at how we got to
where we are
and you talk about all of these cases
and all these high-profile cases
how do we get to the point where the
general public to a large extent whether
it's true or not has such a distaste for
law enforcement it's such a lack i got a
question for respect i agree with you i
got to make some questions to you okay
two questions okay let's go through like
you know the whole question about if we
were to start a country and we have to
recruit people to come and live in our
new country what is the first thing a
mother would be asking first question is
what's next my kids how safe are my kids
okay do you think a mother
feels safer the last two years or they
felt the prior four years
safer do you think they feel safer going
to movie theaters going to dinner their
kids going to school do you think they
feel safer country war all of that so
purely safety
safer or not safer what do you think
you're saying since covet pre-coveted
so we're doing biting trump purely a
question on what i mean covet was the
the in between on all that um i don't
know i'm not
he's talking about violence type
violence specifically
to have people going out there not covet
do you think families feel safer or less
safer today
i don't know i don't want to you know
the answer to the question i don't so
i'm not going to but what you do i'm not
going to give you the answer you don't
want to hear it but they're safer under
trump but let me
to
it's a fact people are scared nowadays
okay do you think people in the borders
2 million the last 12 months it's 2
million this year it's 4.9 million the
last two years by the way you're talking
2 million do you think people on the
southern border feel safe for the last
two years or prior to that well the
southern border that's it's quote
unquote open these days so i would
assume people in the southern border
that you're being fair with that okay do
you think people
are sitting their pockets because that's
how people think as well people are
sitting there feeling better about their
net worth retirement today or they did
two years ago
uh two years ago okay so now here's a
question how many baby boomers
who were relying on retiring their money
they just lost 20 in their portfolio are
sitting there saying i got to work till
70. i got to work till 71. more today or
two years ago yeah
two years ago however we can't discount
covet for being a factor for the
lawlessness that we've seen people have
been locked like
that's like saying this were there more
fights on airplanes two years ago or
more recently i don't know any fights
that were happening three years ago all
of a sudden but that's not all of a
sudden knuckleheads have been locked in
their house
are getting on fights and airplanes
people there's a lot of pensions
joe biden on 60 minutes said covet is
over fauci lost his mind called the
press conference saying it's not over
what he was trying to say is this what
he was trying to say this and the
president just said covet is over
and everybody lost their mind no you
can't say that because we can't do this
again we need people to still be scared
of covered he just said it's over look
no one's wearing masks look at the
dealership look at this one so the
optics are here's basic to me safety
economy finances people felt safer two
years ago than today having said that
having said that
florida republicans watch what florida
republicans said i don't know if you
guys read this article or not florida
republicans prefer ron desantis for
president over donald trump in 2024 paul
this is an insider article this is not a
new york post article this is an insider
article which kind of goes to
a part of what you're saying you're
saying i would much rather have
you know a the census over that so
according to usa today again this is a
liberal poll usa today
uh a poll published wednesday by sue
falk university
florida governor ron desantis leads
former president donald trump 48 to 40
and in a hypothetical 2024 presidential
pride primary there's a reversal from a
similar poll in january in which trump
beat the bestest descent is 47-40 so
exact opposite the poll found a strong
lead for the sentence despite
respondents reporting that they feel
economic conditions in florida were
worsened just 37 of voters said
florida's economy was excellent or good
down from 10 in january so again what
i'm saying is
policies optics but still even with that
more people agree with you today where
they're trying to say if i can get the
same policies without all the other
stuff that's coming with it
so this kind of contradicts what uh uh
ben shapiro said because ben shapiro's
saying hey they're kind of putting them
out out there so people are going to be
wanting to have him but the reality is
independent voters four to one but usa
today saying no people want the santis
no i think i don't think it's
contradicting i think they're both
saying the same thing don't nominate
trump no nominate desantis that's what
both are saying am i wrong i disagree
the way i take it is the phone he says
there's a reason
democrats are eager to keep trump at the
center of the conversation
at the center of the conversation this
usa today if they're really trying to
keep them at the center of conversation
they shouldn't show numbers like this
because numbers like this is getting
people to be convinced to say well i
gotta shift from trump to desantis
that's what i'm saying so i disagree
with ben in the area of the fact that
democrats are put him in the center
front i think they're putting him there
because they're scared of the guy
i think they're scared of him i think i
think they know a guy like that getting
elected okay so who's more who's going
to be a more uh guy that's going to be
uh
vengeance who's more about vengeance
trump him or desantis trump trump okay
if he gets elected what do you think
he's gonna do
i mean he's gonna go after everybody you
know what he's gonna hard now but you
said something you said something
which was very uh powerful you said
you used the following words collateral
damage right
you said i have never ever heard of red
twice editorial sort of general public
on the fbi
so your worry is collateral damage my
worry is this constant back and forth of
revenge revenge revenge revenge revenge
revenge revenge because we're the ones
paying the price guess who loses the
kids and when parents are constantly
going at each other's throats who cares
who loses the kids are the ultimate
losers of that situation so in this case
if it becomes revenge politics the
voters are going to get screwed
in my opinion i may be wrong i agree
the thing with trump and you know
there's a famous quote hell hath no fury
like a woman scorned
right so i'm not calling trump a woman
but the guy feels [ __ ] pissed
okay so
if you're trump and you do get reelected
you don't think you're going to come
after revenge
of course he is
going to get very ugly but the thing is
santa's doesn't have that revenge
factor i mean he's a fighter no doubt
and i think i think that's fine i think
we need a fighter i think we need a
young bold youthful new spirit in the
white house and that's why i would
totally be an advocate for someone like
a desantis but you you if trump gets
reelected you don't think he's gonna
just be pissed and just hell hath no
fury like a scorned woman i'm not
convinced that's what's gonna happen i'm
just not convinced
that the the the media is putting up
trump and
james latisha james and all these guys
are doing it because they want the
republicans to make him as their number
one i'm convinced all the stuff they're
doing
is to eliminate the number one
competitor that's what i'm convinced but
you know what's funny pat that
it's interesting that ben shapiro said
this because ben also said in 2021
that the reason
that there's more people voting for
trump is because the left media keeps
putting him out there and they keep
giving him more and more and more and
more
um uh heat which pisses off the voters
which makes them want to support him
more but what i'm getting this is all
people like you that already have this
but i've been wasn't pissed
but what i'm getting at though is that
this what he said here and i love
benjamin i'm a huge bench burial fan
he's said the opposite just a year ago
or two years ago he said when he was i
forgot who was interviewing him oh no he
it was don lemon
he was don lemon there was a lemon
i don't have any respect for him i could
care less about him and all those guys
at cnn but the point is this that don
lemon
you guys he tells him you guys keep
doing this and that's why he keeps
getting attention because you guys keep
doing this and it's a bad strategy he's
telling him as he's being interviewed on
on cnn so it's kind of like what about
what he's saying now though that's just
weird for him to switch up like that
because it's a switch sentiment can
change right but i just i think it's a
switch of it i think what pat's saying
is right i think they're scared of them
you know they're scared so you gotta you
gotta keep talking by the way i i i pay
attention to what ben is gonna say
because when when i sat down with him in
18
ben said i asked him about biden he says
biden's going to be the next president
he said that in 18 when i sat down with
him at the daily wire headquarters when
they were off of california sherman oaks
or something like that what was his
rationale with that why did he say joe
biden
we talk about rock we talk about trump
we talk about biden he says biden's
going to be the next if he runs biden
once those are his words wow yeah you
can actually he predicted did he give
any more context to that or why he
thought that would happen
i mean i don't i don't know all the
details if you can watch it there's a
short club of it out there but look i
mean it's like when ann coulter said
trump everybody laughed you kind of have
to pay attention to some of this stuff
and nobody's a hundred percent but you
know some people have a better track
record than others so let me can i just
ricky a question yeah why wouldn't if
you're seeing if i'm not saying that you
believe the poll numbers but let's just
play a game here
and you're basically you see the
unfavorable ratings around trump and you
see the favorable ratings that are
trending into santa's direction
why wouldn't you just embrace let me
finish yeah i'm sorry why wouldn't you
just embrace someone like a desantis oh
and get around him oh a hundred percent
a hundred percent i just i just i 100 i
just don't think he's gonna run what do
you want what i don't i don't think i
don't think this is did he say is he out
already that he's gonna i don't i think
it's trending in that direction if you
see these polls that he's already
beating trump but the thing is here's
the thing you gotta remember too so i
said am i following on my instagram when
i talk to people so many people have
flipped i've had people like bro i hated
you four years ago i've been following
you i've been watching all your stuff
and everything you said was true i could
show you messages of people that i can
finally understand what you're talking
about they hated trump they said trump's
a racist troubles this and i was like
bro everything you said was right and
i'm getting those messages every single
day of the year i'm not even joking i'm
not exaggerating one bit
so when i read this i'm like that's
that's it so you trust your own
instagram polls more than
quinnipiac or nbc
this is apart from obviously what i do
with php this is the world i mean i'm
fully in it like i'm i'm in it all the
way apart will be like with lexit when i
go speak at the republican uh uh the
women's republic and i've spoke at two
or three of them are you i'm gonna be
speaking one next month um those rooms
are getting bigger and bigger for people
that were democrats 80 year old women
invite him to be the guest speaker yes
very weird
golf golf what are they called golf uh
golf course uh not the
but the point is this so shut up babe uh
but the point is is here's what i'm
getting at bro those those rooms are
getting fuller and fuller every time i
go and when i'm meeting them because
they talk they walk me around yeah and
it doesn't fail that fifty percent of
them i don't wanna say fifty that'd be
exaggerating thirty percent of the room
they're like i used to vote democrat you
know i'm a republican and this is in
bakersfield california county in the
most yeah where is that baker's well
there's bakersfield central valley and
currently yeah
yeah kern county is one of the only
conservative uh counties in india even
if all the even if 100 of the room was
like all right i'm with you ricky you're
still not going to flip california bro
it's like it's like and i respect what
you're doing 100 percent we're talking
but it's almost like a fruitless
endeavor but we're talking about the
polls i'm not talking about flipping
california talking about what you're
saying there yeah what i'm seeing boots
on the ground is not the same that
that's that that what's that that
whatever that [ __ ] is i'm not saying
there it is there it is from now on
we're gonna put uh quinnipiac all right
pew and then ricky's instagram polls at
the top of the list done
but i think that really quick there's
two things that we're discounting here
trump hasn't been on twitter since what
2018. 2020. what happens
what happens if elon musk
buys twitter and reinstates trump and
trump is now tweeting daily well that's
how many people use this to go back on
twitter and not embrace truth socially
it's far-fetched right let's say trump
gets his voice back how many people does
he turn off and secondly let's say off
turn off because he's now tweeting daily
again which the whole big spiel was no
more mean tweets right people
[ __ ] the policies no more mean tweets
okay secondly let's not forget what
trump did to everybody in the debates
destroyed everybody in the debates he
called
ted's uh ted cruz's wife a dog i mean
little marco rubio
right so either jeb bush whatever low
energy what does he call him right so
how many gram of lesbian basically all
that let's say that trump and desantis
go at it right and he now starts going
an ad hominem attacks on ron desantis
and wins the primaries which he will by
the way which he will i i think it's up
for debatable let's he will do the ad
hominem attacks on ronda santos how many
independent voters has he now yeah he's
going to lose them because he calls ron
de santa's wife a dog or calls him ugly
or what have you know how ugly that's
going to get how many independent voters
does he now turn off how many people
that he has flipped to see now turned
off those 80 year old women they're
saying i'm a big fan of trump and they
they see this yeah you're right it's
true it's a it's a very interesting
perspective and it's it's not
far-fetched very correct so my my take
is he's 76 right now donald trump he'll
be 78
going into the election
i think my crystal ball is that i see
his family paying a price taking a toll
meaning the kids around him
um i see him at that point saying yeah
i'm tapping out
i see him
aligning himself with ron desantis i see
ron desantis being more youthful younger
has a little bit more energy the reality
is if anybody was to go back into office
and take over biden's presidency right
now and just undo the executive office
executive uh orders rescind them we'd be
basically hitting the reset button we'd
be better off for that so
i think
donald trump is probably going to have
way too much baggage at that point that
he himself is even going to recognize
that i think it's one thing for him to
take the hit but i think now as you're
gonna see things come through the funnel
and some of his kids and some of his
real people that
uh are not his hang-ons but really his
blood
i think he's going to take a little bit
of a digression and step back so you
don't think he's going to run is what
you're saying i think it's going to pay
i think it's going to take a heavy toll
on him and not the price of his children
you're saying you're basically saying
he'd be better served not trying to be
the king but the king maker yes sir but
that's not in his dna he views himself
as the number one as the king and it's
going to be hard you brought up his age
it's going to be hard at 76 78 well he's
just flip a script and just say you know
what
but i don't want to be the man anymore
but i have a hard time believing and
here's something interesting we talk
about you know the personal
vindictiveness how many of those trump
supporters are there
that would not be willing to go over to
ron desantis even though if they were
equal meaning the results will be the
same but they'd rather hang on to trump
because they want to see him get his
revenge you're talking about in the
primaries in the process but in the
general electorate they're going to say
i mean
let's just say ricky will take the
sentence over anyone i mean come on you
know let's just say if you could foresee
that the results if santas gets in or
trump gets in we're all going to be
better but there would be more trump
supporters to say i want to see trump
get in because i want to see him pay
these people back yeah you know what
that's the revenge factor big
who would you vote for out of those two
i i like donald trump for the very
reason that he's got that moxie and that
he is no nonsense in your face now with
that being said
i think he he is he's the type of person
that uh you know is hard to control and
hard to read in um
but i like him for getting results he's
result driven last question for you bro
if you were his lawyer i got one more
time
so to reign in what advice would you
give to trump if you were his lawyer so
he gave it right off the bat i don't
know if you caught it no so i'm asking
i'm circling back for that he gave it
right off look
listen i have clients i tell each and
every client that comes into the office
my job is to ensure make sure you don't
drive off that cliff that's why you're
paying me to you're hiring me to prevent
you from driving off that cliff and if
you're insisting in driving off that
cliff i'm gonna tell you right now
i'm bailing on you i'm getting out of
that car and you can drive off that
cliff by yourself i'm not your guy a lot
of people look at me like what do you
mean you have to have that ability a
good lawyer has to have client control
donald trump is impossible to control
because he believes in his own little
way he knows more than anybody he does
he believes that and when you deal with
someone who believes that it's
impossible to get them to take your
advice just as i said when he went on
sean hannity last night i he said things
that i even gasped at he talked about a
form that's a page and a half if you
remember he talked about this page and a
half of a disclaimer form where his
company puts it out and they put
everybody on notice well let me be
honest with you the government
department of justice they got that
going right now and they have a
transcription person that's transcribing
that interview because he better make
sure that everything he said to sean
hannity does in fact play out as a
lawyer i would say donald do me a favor
keep your mouth shut take a back seat
not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen we go round and
round in circles i wish you would listen
to someone like you i really wish well
not gonna happen though no it's not
gonna happen last thing here before we
wrap up putin you guys saw the story
about putin with
uh the back and forth with the threats
about nuclear and then biden also coming
back
uh when uh
they were both speaking i want to read
this and kind of get your commentary and
then we'll wrap up so
uh uh putin initiates a conscription to
a bolster military invasion and you at
the ukraine mount uh counter-offensive
uh russia president vladimir putin
announced a partial mobilization of
russia which will require citizens to
join the war effort in ukraine it's a
fully uh adequate to the threats we face
namely to protect our homeland it's
sovereignty and territorial integrity to
ensure the security of our people and
people in the liberated territories we
are talking about partial mobilization
that is only citizens who are currently
in the reserve will be subject to
conscription and above all those who
served in the armed forces have a
certain military specialty
and relevant experience and he warns the
west
threat to resort to nuclear weapons this
is not a bluff putin issued a warning
after accusing western countries of
resorting to nuclear blackmail despite
no nato countries threatening to use
nuclear weapons to those who allow
themselves such statements
regarding russia i want to remind you
and he's only talking on one person by
the way
that our country also has various means
of destruction
and for separate components and more
modern than those of nato countries
and when the territorial integrity of
our country is threatened to protect
russia and our people we will certainly
use all the means at our disposal it's
not a bluff
the threat comes as russia's pro
prospects in ukraine are grim with
putin's military losing thousands of
square miles of territory to ukrainian
counter-offensive and by the way
he's saying this
this is my idea with this
you know we've talked about this before
what'd you say i'll kick your ass say
that again look what i'm gonna do to you
maybe you can get away with it once
twice three if you keep doing that
people gonna be like dude shut up do
something right yeah okay so now to to
flip you know flip that
uh is
people are moving out of russia at a
record-breaking rate
so earlier we were talking about you're
saying tell me one other country that's
getting the most people i wanted to kind
of talk about this i said let's just
wrap up our lago conversation germany
they're leaving russia no but i'm saying
they're going into germany they're going
all over the place but they're just
leaving russia they're worried okay like
when we lived in iran the war was going
on like dudes this could get new clears
our families were just worried about the
safety of the kids so people were
leaving no matter where they get a
chance to go to they're just leaving so
he's in a very tough situation so now
you go and look at uh pearl harbor and
then what happened fdr and then truman
goes and calls it and here let's go do
this and drop it and hey we saw what
happened to you know hiroshima
do you take his threat as a bluff or do
you take it as this guy's got his back
so much against the wall right now that
if there is a guy that would do it it
would be him
i think he should be taken seriously but
i do believe that his own civil unrest
within his own company within his own
country is going to be his ultimate
downfall meaning his own people are
turning on him and are going to continue
to rise up i think that's where nato and
especially with the united states having
their allies work on the russian
population to expose him for being just
who he is a madman i think eventually
will back him down and eventually create
his downfall now with that being said
the reality is right now with him having
the ability to push a button
uh you know the unfortunately ukraine
there's not much to destroy there right
i mean it's basically a vast wasteland i
mean he's destroyed basically the the
entire country um with respect to using
nuclear weapons my biggest concern
honestly is not
his ability to carry out that threat
my biggest concern to myself
and to my family and to our to my fellow
americans is honestly
what would be
the response if god help us all
if he was to
uh implement a nuclear attack because we
all know
what will happen if he does it
or we can anticipate what would happen
my biggest concern is what's the
response because once you light that
fuse
we may be looking
at a completely different world than
we've ever known before
you know the difference between the
button and us versus russia
did you have you seen that article
okay so you know on u.s the button is
controlled by who
president one person
he can't push the button there he needs
multiple multiple approvals in russia
so russia's situation is not like what'd
you say boom that's u.s that's not what
it is in russia
so that gives a little bit of comfort to
say you have to convince three or five
people whatever the amount of people is
for them to say
we agree that it's time to push the
button so
i think for the world that's a little
bit worried it's good that russia's
button to the nuclear bomb is a lot more
regulated believe it or not as weird as
it sounds
than the button in the us now you uh do
you remember what tate had to say about
this no
you asked tate this question
misunderstood man exactly you said you
live in romania which is on the border
of ukraine ukraine war you're seeing
this happening you know this is when we
were in madrid doing the interview with
tate and obviously we didn't talk about
putin for an extended period of time
throughout that interview but basically
you brought up the term madman and he
goes i know that term gets thrown around
a lot putin's a madman is a madman he's
crazy and he goes no i think he's
actually a rational actor but he
he is there to serve his country mother
russia he's not worried about global
agendas or
poll numbers he's there for one reason
only to take a term from your president
or president uh make russia great again
so i think i don't think he's a bad man
i think he's a rational actor i don't
think he wants to blow up the world i
don't think he wants to do that at the
same time what i do think he has is a
massive ego
and i think he needs an off-ramp to save
face right now he's not winning this war
in ukraine you know the the eu united
states is throwing billions of dollars
to prop up ukraine and fight russia and
they're doing an uh
a good job of it and i think if you're
if you're putin and if you want if
you're the world and you want a safe
world you want to give at least putin an
opportunity to not look weak and to save
face and give him an off ramp so he
doesn't do anything illogical and he
maintains the rational actor status
my
take is though his dna
because of where he came from is all
about deception
and killing and murder kgb kgb and
poisoning and of course doing things and
accidentally jumping out of it
or doing the most barbaric things of
course i think that's his dna and and
look madman is you know someone who's
crazy i don't i think he's very
calculated no doubt no question very
smart very calculated my biggest or my
fear is
because of his dna he does not have the
ability to think beyond himself
meaning that and just as patrick said
there's a layer that insulates him from
getting to that button
my concern would be he'll start knocking
off those people and putting in people
in their place to ultimately get to that
button who's a bigger egomaniac putin or
trump
well look you see trump in front of the
camera a lot more than you see putin
that's for sure so that may just be
well and
we're all assuming that this is a big
nuclear weapon he has targeted nuclear
weapons he can launch very small nuclear
attacks and and create mass devastation
and listen i don't think he's a madman i
think he's very calculated but we are
pushing him and pushing him and push
imagine how frustrated he has to be that
he can't take over ukraine because like
adam said worse than in 50 60 70 80 100
billion dollars what do you think he's
gonna do we're it's no secret that that
we are fighting a proxy war against
russia on behalf of ukraine what do you
expect him to do so what happens when
you push a bully one too many times
what happens the bully goes home goes
into his father's closet gets out his
assault rifle puts it in his backpack
and comes to school the next day and say
okay here's the great equalizer and
that's what we see in these mass
shootings and so be careful pushing
putin into that corner because that's
what are they that's the key though
that's not him being a madman that's not
him being crazy that's that's that's our
problem we did this we set this up this
is our fault this is why i'm saying we
need to give him an off ramp and the
opportunity to at least save face and
not look weak
there was a there was a question by
hannah yesterday about putin
and he says uh what did you say to putin
behind closed doors that got put into
and i want to attack ukraine he says i
can't tell you that that's between me
and him in the conversation but we did
have a respectable uh i don't know if
you caught that one part yeah so
diplomacy
is different you know like in in
insurance like uh be having been in a
sales organization for the last 20 years
there are guys
very few guys are good at two things
there are guys that are very good from
stage very good from stage
and it makes you believe they're better
one-on-one but they suck one-on-one suck
101 they're good stage right so there's
three levels too there's stage there's
group setting u and five and there's one
on one okay
and then there are those guys that are
very good one-on-one but they suck on
stage
i used to think the guy on stage would
build the biggest business
but it's the guy that was the best at
101 that built the biggest business
because he knew how to get things done
and he would move things forward so the
one-on-one unfortunately none of us can
gauge because there is no camera on
one-on-one so we don't know how biden is
one-on-one we don't know how trump is
one-on-one but obviously when trump was
doing one-on-one
nothing was happening isis disappeared
putin was calm nothing was going on
there so the power of the one-on-one
unfortunately we will never be able to
gauge ever because there's no cameras in
the one-on-one having said that quick
shout out to a couple of the guys that
gave the super chat
joseph the kelaita a syrian guy you said
there's only seven famous i'm one of
seven famous assyrians in the world he
says make me the eighth because there's
not too many syrians
appreciate you
uh pro procatis says uh what his stance
is on patriot act we didn't get into the
patriot act that's something we talked
to giuliani about when it comes to trump
this is paul 20 when it comes to trump
the democrats keep beating the same drum
hoping people will dance to the beat
unfortunately they are tone deaf and
trump will come out victorious once
again we will see
then we had andrew said adam yes there
is that saying but remember schumer said
the intelligence agencies will get you
six ways from sunday about trump funny
it's happening now and then we have a uh
jason said trump is a criminal he is
finally held to the fire okay
and then we have derek said now they've
changed it to hell has no fury like adam
scorn adam had
adam has the emotions of a woman i'm
offended by that one anyways
okay gang uh the tyler do we have
something this week or this is the one
and then later on today adam has a
podcast with ricky if you want to be
entertained don't miss that one on if
you want to see ricky and fireworks tune
in to sas cast 4 p.m by the way shout
out to my driver julio i got a driver
here in florida now because he's sick
dominican republic big fan of the
podcast he's like always like he lives
two minutes for you i see that you they
see what you're saying right here i love
it well gang uh if you enjoyed stuart as
much as we did give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and hopefully
we'll have him back on the podcast again
brother appreciate you for coming out
this was very helpful thank you thank
you stuart thank you everybody have a
great weekend bye bye bye bye
you